[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today we're discussing albus dumbledore
and nine awful things he did in the name
of the greater good
albus dumbledore was the greatest wizard
of the 20th century but he was also
strangely one of the most reckless
in fact if you took a look at a full
list of the headmaster's decisions you'd
find yourself shaking your head quite a
lot
wondering how someone so smart could
simultaneously be so awful today we're
going to take a look at some of these
choices
we'll break down why exactly dumbledore
thought he was in the right and why his
decisions ended up being so awful
sent harry to the dursleys if you know
the true reason why dumbledore sent
harry potter to live with the dursleys
then you might be wondering why it would
be considered awful
after all living with the dursleys might
have been the only thing protecting
harry during his childhood
thanks to an ancient form of magic if
harry lived with the blood relative of
his mothers then the same power that
prevented voldemort from killing harry
as an infant would carry over to his new
guardians
unfortunately for harry his mother had
no other family besides aunt petunia if
albus dumbledore could have found harry
potter a less abusive home than he
surely would have but with no other way
to maintain the protection around harry
the hogwarts headmaster was forced to
compromise with himself
in order to save harry's life he had to
condemn him to a childhood of neglect
and abuse a fact that he often felt
guilty about had harry potter been
anyone else he might not have survived
such a traumatic childhood within the
dursley home
in a more emotionally unstable child
such abuse would have resurfaced as
terrible violent traits
voldemort himself developed many of his
murderous beliefs after surviving his
own brutal childhood
neglected tom riddle
it's hard not to compare harry potter's
childhood with that of tom riddle often
when contrasting the two you can't help
but wonder what tom would have been like
if only a single adult had cared about
him
even after albus dumbledore arrived at
the orphanage that housed riddle he
rarely offered the boy any type of
affection
quite a contrast to how he treated harry
a few decades later
in his first interaction with riddle
dumbledore marveled at his natural
ability in magic and he was also
disheartened by the darkness that seemed
to surround tom in that moment and the
years that followed albus might have
been able to undo all of the years of
abuse that riddle had suffered if he
only showed some compassion might riddle
have learned to quiet his rage
but in the end albus didn't do anything
of the sword he simply recruited tom for
hogwarts and gave him a small stipend
with which to buy supplies
sending the child alone to diagon alley
to figure out the wizarding world for
himself
even in later years as dumbledore
suspiciously watched tom manipulate the
other hogwarts staff albus remained
quiet
instead of addressing the issue
dumbledore hoped that tom's darkness
would resolve itself on its own
by the time dumbledore realized tom's
psychosis would lead to the rise of lord
voldemort it was too late
he treated snape like a pawn
after severus snape realized the error
of his ways and abandoned the death
eaters he sought help from albus
dumbledore
in the years that followed dumbledore
ensured that snape would have a place at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry a kind gesture to be sure
but the headmaster also planned to use
severus snape to further his own agenda
the continued fight against the dark
arts
when forces conspired to steal the
philosopher's stone and later when
voldemort's return was confirmed albus
dumbledore leaned on severus more than
any other ally
the weight of albus friendship along
with the grief he still bore for lily
potter's death meant that severus could
never live a normal life
perhaps if albus was anyone different he
would have realized that the burden he
placed on severus was too great
instead if dumbledore helped snape
process his guilt then the potions
master could somehow live a normal
fuller life
but dumbledore's own life was far from
normal and he saw no problem with
leading snape down a similar path
responsible for sirius's death
albus dumbledore wasn't directly
responsible for sirius black's death but
he certainly had a role to play
during the events of the order of the
phoenix albus dumbledore strangely
decided to ignore harry potter the
elderly headmaster believed that by
neglecting harry he could somehow
protect the boy from the horrors of the
war to come
as you can probably tell by now albus
dumbledore often kept his own counsel he
would consider a scenario rely on
himself to come up with a solution and
put it into effect without getting a
second opinion from anyone else
and that's why he ended up hurting so
many people by simply cutting harry out
of the picture he spurred the young
wizard to investigate matters on his own
that eventually led harry into trap that
voldemort and the death eaters had lain
in order to save harry's life sirius
black and the other older members of the
order of the phoenix blindly leapt into
action
in the end black lost his life and harry
nearly lost his all because dumbledore
thought he could do everything on his
own
lied about harry's fate
did harry potter need to die
in the story it seems that way or at
least that's what albus dumbledore
communicated to severus snape in his
memories but when harry learned that he
needed to give his life he presumed that
it was a one-way ticket to the afterlife
he had no idea that he would be able to
survive the duel with lord voldemort
when voldemort fought against harry and
the deathly hallows the dark wizard
merely managed to kill the accidental
horcrux that resided as part of harry
and since voldemort had reconstructed
his new body using potter's blood
then he inherited the protective spell
that harry himself had been given in the
moment his mother died over a decade
prior
all that might sound a bit confusing
but it simply meant that harry actually
didn't face certain death if he jeweled
voldemort something that would have been
nice to know prior to the battle
ariana's death
during albus dumbledore's youth he made
one of the most foolish decisions of his
life
he conspired with gaelic grindelwald to
take over the wizarding world
albus was young dumb and infatuated with
grindelwald during that era there was
very little hope of changing albus mind
but his brother aberforth tried to
anyway
the young brother confronted both albus
and grindelwald about their plan and
after heated debate the situation
devolved into a jewel
it's hard to know who would have won but
before the conflict came to an end
albus's sister ariana tried to intervene
in the process the 14 year old sibling
died
her life which had already been filled
with innumerable tragedies was cut short
by albus's own recklessness something he
would never forget although throughout
the rest of his life his same bad habit
of taking on leadership roles would
always seem to be his undoing the ring
decades later still devastated by the
loss of his sister albus dumbledore
foolishly tried to destroy voldemort's
horcruxes all on his own
but once when he finally located the
ring of marvel gaunt dumbledore let his
guard down
voldemort didn't realize it at the time
he transformed the ancient black jewelry
but it actually wasn't just a simple
heirloom
the stone within the ring was none other
than a deathly hallow
according to myth that rock the
resurrection stone has the ability to
recall spirits from the dead
desperate to see his sister again
dumbledore forgot all reason and slid
the ring along his finger
in an instant he was struck by the
deadly curse voldemort had placed on the
ring
and even though albus managed to halt
the spread of the curse thanks to
snape's help the damage was already done
within a year dumbledore would die
leaving the defense of the wizarding
world in the hands of harry potter who
was only a schoolboy at the time
entrusting hagrid with security
nobody likes to criticize ruby's
handgrid
even though the hogwarts groundskeeper
was often reckless with magical beasts
albus dumbledore felt a special fondness
for the half giant but that fondness
often exposed hogwarts and its students
to life and death risks
during harry potter's very first year at
the school dumbledore's decision to
trust hagrid's guard dog a three-headed
hound named fluffy proved nearly fatal
hagrid revealed the secret to bypassing
the dog in a game with professor
quirrell which ultimately led the
possessed wizard to the same room as the
philosopher's stone
bringing philosopher stone to hogwarts
but utilizing fluffy wasn't even
dumbledore's worst decision that year
the headmaster was the one who brought
nicola flamel's philosopher's stone into
hogwarts
by placing such a powerful alchemical
relic within the school albus placed the
lives of each and every one of the
students at risk
dumbledore felt that hogwarts was a
safer place than gringotts but the
headmaster also foolishly believed that
professor quirrell was an upstanding
instructor
both lapses in judgment nearly cost
harry potter his life
while trying to prevent quirrell from
getting his hands on the stone harry and
his friends ended up in the hospital
with serious injuries it was only the
start of their long journey of cleaning
up dumbledore's messes
and that's it for this video if you
enjoyed the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you